[Musique]
alors que la feria de nîmes avait lieu
le week-end dernier l'actrice française
carole bouquet a été photographié en
train d'assister à une corrida un acte
dénoncé sur twitter par la ligue des
animaux une association qui défend le
bien-être animal carole bouquet était
présente à la corrida de nîmes ce
week-end elles figurent donc parmi la
liste des people cautionnant la cruauté
envers les animaux la corrida doit être
abolie ce poste après les tueries un
déferlement de haine envers l'actrice
est quant à elle s'agace un peu le mythe
de la femme élégante et distinguée
finalement une personne avec une âme
moche et perverse l'éducation des
enfants passe par le respect de toute
forme de vie honte à vous madame bouquet
par merde alors elle descend dans mon
estime d'un coup là c'est carole bouquet
n'a pas réagi d'autres la défense
dénonçant une chasse aux sorcières alors
carole bouquet critiqué pour avoir
assisté à une corrida comprenez vous la
polémique
et nous recevons ont gagné 6 ya dix
comédiens et vous êtes passionné par la
corrida vous défendez alors je le dis
assez considéré comme un art c'est oui
c'est considéré comme un art par les
gens qui connaissent la corrida qu'il
aime en tout cas alors il ya encore 70
corrida chaque année en france en
espagne en a mille huit cent
depuis que les corridas existe il ya eu
60 l'un des leurs qui ont perdu la vie
et 40000 taureau qui ont été tuées en
europe chaque année c'est beaucoup voilà
ce qu'est rien comparé à la viande qu'on
mange
il a raison
je sens que ça grince un peu quand même
la tauromachie attire 6 millions de
spectateurs donc c'est pas un marché
gigantesque quand même et c'est le
deuxième spectacle de masse après le
football même allez donc saisi ses seins
cerner je vous dis une bêtise et je
souhaite 14% des français veulent
interdire la corrida comment est ce que
vous pourriez convaincre ceux qui nous
regardent et certainement del cine
spisak un train de se masquer je ne dis
pas le me regarde pas ce qu'on voit
comment est-ce qu'on peut défendre la
corrida c'est vrai que moi je vous dis
je trouve ça le spectacle trouve très
beau je suis pas fan de la mise à mort
c'est très difficile de
défendre la corrida rapidement comme ça
mais ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
avant d'avoir un avis sur la corrida il
est important de s'intéresser à la
corrida moi ça fait deux ans que je vais
aux corridas et avant de m'y intéresser
jeux jeux ce spectacle me révulse est
ensuite j'ai lu sur la corrida je me
suis intéressé je me suis rendu j'ai
rencontré les éleveurs je me suis rendu
dans les élevages et je me suis rendu
compte que c'était le contraire de ce
que je pensais donc déjà je voudrais
essayer de convaincre jambes avant
d'avoir un avis sur la corrida de
saintes de soutien connexes est
sérieusement ensuite sur les questions
de souffrances à un animal c'est très
très très compliqué d'en discuter
rapidement il ya une étude qui a été
faite par la faculté de médecine de
madrid que les gens peuvent consulter
qui montre que le taureau est un est un
animal qui dégagent une agressivité
naturelle
surdimensionné dans le règne animal et
d'ailleurs je vous mets au défi de
trouver une vidéo de corridas dans
lequel vous allez voir un taureau montré
des signes de douleur je ne dis pas
qu'il a pas mal je dis que non mais je
veux dire et dire non mais on ne
pourrait pas faire la corrida avec un on
ne pourrait pas faire ce qu'on fait à la
corrida avec un cheval ou avec un stern
s'il paraît aux yeux verts en fuyant
pardon est-ce qu'il est résistant parce
qu'il est résistant et persanes taureau
de tendance à charmes mais non mais on
s'acharne pas ce qu'il faut rappeler
aussi c'est que le taureau c'est un
animal c'est le toro brave cette race de
taureaux c'est un animal qui se bat
naturellement avec ses congénères qui
tissent il se sait pas qui équipe ça
fait partie de sa vie votre vie avoue la
règle entre toro veut avec d'autres non
mais alors là oui donc les autoroutes
et l'après merci à réapprendre les rssi
le taureau le taureau se bat
naturellement les combats entre toro
dure des heures des heures de souffrance
et ensuite ils passent leur temps avec
les tripes à l'air une nuit entière
avant de mourir le combat dans une arène
dure 15 minutes et les souffrances sont
très relatif par rapport au combat
naturel du taureau contre un autre
taureau alors là et l'on vous dira oui
d'accord enfin c'est bien les animaux
s'affrontent dans la vie c'est leur vie
c'est pas quelqu'un qui est intervenu et
on n'a pas dit aux taureaux et dit non
tu veux pas les bastonner le copain à
côté donc c'est passé par des assurés se
passe moi je vous dis quand on voit les
images mais en années notamment de mai à
mort quand on voit le taux qui rate et
blanc qui se vide de son sang par les
narines par l'abe horrible qu'il agonise
pendant plusieurs minutes et qu'on vient
d'achever avec un truc donc pris voilà
c'est moi je comprends très bien que ça
révulse simon c est franchement j'aime
bien les études qu'ils ont fait sur la
souffrance du taureau enfin mon avis ils
sauront ils sont le taureau souffre
payer ses études sûrement
alors les filles vous évidemment 22 on
est tellement évolué on évolue
absolument surtout je trouve que c'est
pratique c'est un autre temps je pense
que ça ce n'est pas un art ce n'est pas
ma culture il faut savoir que la corrida
c'est illégal parce que c'est un acte de
cruauté c'est uniquement autorisés dans
les villes taurines oui ça veut dire que
si vous faites ça votre art vous le
faites à paris vous pouvez risques et
deux ans d'emprisonnement et 30 mille
euros damende ça veut bien dire que ce
n'est pas légal ces sévices et que c'est
de la cruauté enfin c'est puisque vous
ne feriez pas ça sur votre chien par
exemple vivant au taureau c'est là où
vous comprenez rien ne
laissait rien aux animaux ça ça vous
excusez moi vous parlez aux chasseurs
vous parlez aux paysans vous parlez aux
gens du sud de la france qui comprennent
la tauromachie ils vont vous rire au nez
parce que vous vous êtes une citadine
qui ne comprennent rien à
ma vie et me paraît un chien tout
remettre un chien n'est pas un tour mais
franchement elle a joué excusez moi mais
le écrit par exemple le chien et le
taureau il n'y a pas lieu en avoir
excusez moi non mais c'est pas moi c'est
moi qui fais la comparaison parce qu un
taureau c'est un animal comme un chien
ou comme un chat et je veux dire nous ré
ou très con transperce un chat ou un
chien et où un cheval est on le fait
pour un taureau le service et le même
c'était illégal et la majorité des
français sont contre dont la majorité
des français ne comprennent rien oui
justement justement ya une étude eudes a
eu un sondage qui vient d'être fait par
ifop fiducial qui a été publiée par sud
radio qui est intéressant puisqu'il
donne c'est un sondage fait dans les
villes taurines qui ont des arènes de
première catégorie comme nikon riziers
bas également dans ces villes 57 % des
gens ont déjà assisté à une corrida dans
le sud est soit les 71% des jeux de ces
gens pas des gens qui ont un système
qu'on l'aide à 71 % des habitants des
villes taurines
sont pour le maintien de la corrida ce
qui veut dire que dans les villes dans
lesquelles il ya une culture taurine et
dans laquelle les gens ont massivement
assister aux corridas ils n'ont pas du
tout la même vision de la corrida que
des gens qui n'y comprennent rien et me
connesson si je ferais si et combien et
combien dans ces villes sont contre la
mise à mort oui beaucoup combien 70% et
pour ça la question avant c'est pourquoi
pourquoi pour rêver un peu le problème
puisque c'est un aspect plus voilà
l'affrontement de l'homme et de l'animal
et te voilà c'est un beau spectacle
yangon
pourquoi ils ont besoin à chaque fois
ridley de les tuer avec c'est avec cet
ep qui fort plus je vous le dis parce
que je me suis un peu renseigné l'espace
il est grand comme ça l'espadrille
poursuit le taureau oui c'est gros comme
ça c'est impossible de passer à côté
faut la refaire faut la refaire et moi
j'ai vu des et le matador à une amende
si la réussite c'est pour pas faire que
ça car la menthe à la meilleure pourquoi
est il alors répète une explication
culturel c'est peut-être le laissez pas
l'aboutissement le leu leu foxes il faut
être clair la corrida on tue c'est
l'histoire de la mort matador c'est une
histoire c'est une histoire qui raconte
celui qui met à mort matin elle m'a taxé
trader costumes en or tout significatif
meriane provient attendait juste une
question juste je trouve quand même il
ya deux choses le sujet déjà après
chasser l'actrice carole bouquet juste
aurait cette parenthèse carole bouquet
si elle veut aller voir une corrida moi
je vais voir les corridas parce que tu
parlais tout à l'heure dareta culture
comme tu le dis ce n'est pas ta culture
donc tu ne peux pas encore la connaître
donc quand on connaît pas on peut avoir
un jugement mais pas peut-être pas aussi
peut-être pointilleux que la fota qui
intéresse un peu plus mais je comprends
que tu n'aimes pas car le bouquet elle a
le droit d'avoir une corrida et on
jugera bouquin j'ai quand même avoir
connu une corrida c'est ce carnage mais
[ __ ] de merde on a encore le droit
dans notre pays atteint je t'ai laissé
par l'esma finir on a encore le droit de
voir ce qu'on veut quand il ya des
combats de coqs dans certains pays mes
combats de chiens c'est ça on va les
voir on peut ne pas tolérer et tu aimes
ça c'était ça non mais c'est pas ma
culture
je l'aimais
laissez moi finir un taureau de corrida
il meurt dans l'arène à cinq ans un
taureau la bouche filmera deux ans alors
tu admires oui mais meurt d'un coup il
ya là beaucoup plus qu'ils meurent alors
certes c'est une mise à mort différentes
mais c'est une culture est aujourd'hui
la cruche ac mais alors mais tu peux le
voir comme ça mais quand j'entends les
dom zuma
où les gens aujourd'hui la liberté bien
sûr d'aller voir comme carole bouquet et
moi cet été j'ai pris mon amendement
mayotte parce que c'est ma culture ma
fille va elle aime ma mère des tests
mais aujourd'hui en france ce qu'il faut
faire et avancer c'est accepter que les
gens aient des différences il y en a qui
aiment y en a qui aiment pas et on n'a
pas besoin de redire son éditeur qui
s'était des trous du cul parce qu'ils
vont voir quelque chose qui à l'encontre
de ce qu'on pense et c'est ça le
problème en france et aujourd'hui on n'a
pas le droit de regarder différemment
des hommes est-ce que vous pouvez
entendre le moi j'ai un argument qui me
paraît évident c'est la souffrance de
l'animal c'est papa après le reste
nettement qu'ils fassent des danses auto
avec son machin son chapeau ridicule et
c'est vrai que très bien qu'elle a
beaucoup d'animaux chez elle elle et
elle vit dans un domaine en italie etc
et est là et non elle est entourée par
les animaux et elle est plutôt voilà
savait comment restaurant le corridor on
avait dans l'arène donc c'est vrai qu
est une espèce d'antinomie on se dit
c'est que ça non qu'est ce qu'elle fait
là je peux comprendre que ça chaque au
sanatorium mourir pendant cinq ans dans
un cargo qui fait des milliers
d'hectares c'est à dire qu'il n'est pas
tenu dans un parc comme ça à l'abattoir
avant de passer avec un coup de jus à
l'âge de deux ans pendant cinq ans il
est dans des dents des grands parcs pour
se développer pour grandir après il est
séparé et oui il est mis à mort dans une
arène mais il a gagné déjà trois arbres
alors vous me direz peut-être dans des
situations peu différente mais il a eu
une belle riche qu'à cinq ans quand vous
voyez où lé reportage à martin va quand
on traite les cochons les taureaux les
moutons comment traite les gens et vous
me dis que ça pour arrêter et bien alors
peut-être il faut faire comme toi faut
plus beauf et le gagner on arrête tout
il faut écouter il faut écouter parler
les éleveurs de taureaux moi par exemple
suis très proche d'une famille
d'éleveurs de taureaux la famille marge
et élèves des taureaux exceptionnel mois
olivier margé et robert margé me disent
qu'ils élèvent des taureaux de combat il
enlève aussi des bêtes pour pour deux
pour la viande quand ils emmènent leurs
taureaux à la corrida ils y vont heureux
d'accompagner leurs taureaux quand ils
emmènent les met à l'abattoir les gens
me disent pourtant dans des abattoirs
ils connaissent ou les bêtes winzip
c'est pas tout ça gâche ils ont les
larmes aux yeux la gauche serré c'est un
peu schizophrénique sous louis
si les poussières toutes ses dents alors
pardon quand on voit effectivement le
monde à travers un prisme culturel bien
sûr que tous nous paraît acceptable tout
à l'heure jean pascal parlait de fameux
combat de coqs et combats de chiens
c'est ma culture aux antilles il ya des
spectacles comme ça moi je nombreux
tests tu t'es d'accord pour moi je
réprouve je n'aime pas pour mieux la
culture devrait être synonyme de chute
que non même que l'excision à la ccb sur
et j'allais dire et
l'isoler demain à l'époque aussi en
france il y en avait c'était dans la
culture alors parce que ça existait
exact de continuer à exister nous allons
en données non mais lorsque vous dites
heures monsieur et je vous respecte ya
pas de souci maintenant quand vous me
dites que oui l'éleveur il a la boule au
ventre quand il emmène à l'abattoir hip
hop et pas quand il envisage le jeune
homme l'a trouvée d'ici là c'est
difficile d'avoir un avis mais sans
coach et le droit d'avoir un avis sur
mer je vous dit j'ai pas besoin d'aller
vers des détours et voilà mais c'est
la vie même
j'ai regardé faire traîner mes enfants
mais je la
suis pas d'accord avec vous parce qu
annonce avait causé une bonne image de
la corrida il faut accepter qu'il y ait
des gens qui
ne vont pas la voix elle a son avis et
chacun et c'est comme ça que la corrida
façon elle disparaît mais je dis pas le
contraire je dirais juste que
je veux juste que c'est intéressant
d'entendre que vous dites bien avoir un
avis sur la corde de la fff
est-ce que l'argument est ce que ce
texte a dit une chose très juste sous
couvert de la culture la tradition on
devrait accepter tout et n'importe quoi
la tradition c'est pas un argument pour
pourquoi parce qu'en fait la tradition
où la culture c'est des choses qui se
sont fait un avant et ça veut y avait
une rumeur quand on acceptait quand on
pouvait exécuter quelqu'un sur la place
publique voilà sauf que ces traditions
les duels aux est la zone
la lapidation c'est traditionnel on a
raté sa saison veut dire ah bon c'est
culturel et lorsqu'on évolue à certaines
traditions dont on doit ces débats si
c'est le mot doit alors ça veut dire que
s'il ya des gens par exemple qui sont
contre des choses moins négatif que ça
sénégal il souffre c'est les fabriques
peuple ici c'est vrai mais pas trop
parce qu'elle s'est passé cette semaine
à 10 ans et voila c'est direct à qui si
elle répète ça l'aplasie toros avait
bien dit que ma positif belle autoroute
a gagné trois armes c'est ce que je me
disais avant toi moi je comprends que tu
aimes pas dans l'émotionnel il faut en
effet révisé de la meute chocolat non
c'est pas de la mauvaise foi c'est je
comprends le tuer non c'est pas
magnifique
imaginons il reçoit
une passe et on a on enlève juste la
mise à mort mais ces candidatures il
faut savoir qu'il ya des corridas non
piquée à la
mort et la misère ça n'a aucun sens la
corrida c'est l'histoire de la mort
c'est un spectacle qui raconte la main
oui mais c'est indéfendable la corrida
sarko temps moi j'ai du mal à imaginer
que 100% des humains puissent vivre sans
tuer des animaux pour les manger
malheureusement autant je pense qu'on
peut se passer d'un spectacle on se
réjouit de la mort d'un filtre à steam
et mes pratiques d'un autre temps
aujourd'hui on va bien il ya de moins en
moins d'animaux dans les cirques y en a
de moins en moins dans les eaux y aurait
plus sur les plastiques les maquettes
sont des pratiques d'un autre temps donc
faut évoluer vivre avec son temps ses
complices elle a échoué nice et vous
êtes au rire et moi j'suis un grain fin
de la corrida vraiment j'ai beaucoup
d'amis matador et touchera une grande
passionnée depuis toujours et je vous
trouve quand même parce que si on veut
faire aimer ou comprends je trouve quand
même un peu piquant 8 matérialise tout
ça il faut comprendre aussi ces gens qui
ont pas su que les jurys ont donc faux
pas de thé je pense peut-être pas dire
matérialiste je comprends que ça chauffe
vous comprenez pas tellement qu'il vous
dit si on met pacte euro à mort ça sert
à rien banon mais l'islande mais en quoi
védas et mais oui mais c'est l'histoire
de lakovic non excusez-moi je peux poser
une question que sans la corrida crise
mais non mais déjà amusé stéphane hummel
quand même écouter wagner où je trace je
vais pas m'amuser non c'est pas mal je
vous dirais tu es c'est un sujet sans
fin ne trouvera jamais de te clés voilà
moi j'ai
juste un homme aussi
je voudrais juste dire aux
téléspectateurs que s'ils veulent un
devoir un avis il ya un livre très bien
fait qui s'appelle philosophie de la
corrida du philosophe francis wolff
c'est très documenté lisez ça ça vous
donne envie d'aller aux arènes aller aux
arènes et vous en avez passé
merci